There's a lot of talk of an internet about using castor oil in your belly button. What is your opinion?
Well, I already shared my opinion about talk on the internet
But this is been a hot topic. I actually saw a video of this as well. Now as you know in your binder
We have information about using castor oil packs under liver and people have asked about castor oil over tubers
Over their breast over and I told you to shy away from that because we've had people with some bad experience
When you do a castor oil pack over the breast tuber or over another tuber
Castor oil is
Is really is actually a caustic oil so it is kind of toxic
So if you took castor oil
Orally which in the past you could see medical books back in the early 1900s would recommend oral
Table spoon of castor oil better factor was recommended for women that were pregnant that they were maybe
overdue in their pregnancy to take a table spoon of castor oil and it could help bring out the pregnancy
And the reason why that is maybe possible is because it is caustic
It's typically going to cause you to have a ball movement and just having that ball movement getting your balls moving
Was thought to be helpful with moving a pregnancy along and it may or may not have been true
Typically, we do not recommend taking castor oil orally
So I think it could be toxic to your liver
You know, especially if you did it on a regular basis so we don't recommend that
The reason why a castor oil pack works is that it
You absorb some of the product you don't absorb it all that castor oil you have a skin barrier
But it will help flush the liver so I think it can be beneficial can do a castor oil
Packs on your chest if you have a pneumonia be helpful. Yes, it can be really helpful putting castor oil
If you have a really bad cough or pneumonia
It can be helpful to kind of flush out the lungs
Doing castor oil packs over your belly in your abdominal area
Could that help with bowel movements and help with detox in your bowel? Yes, it could
Doing castor oil in your belly button as kind of the new thing
What's the benefit of that? Well, um, I
Firstly, don't think there is one at all. So no
Again, I do think a lot of influencers out there are just kind of
Going with stuff because anything new out there can get a lot of clicks and a lot of followers
And you have to be really careful with that like I said in the past I saw an influencer saying everybody should be we need copper
So everybody should be drinking from copper cups and using copper pans
Well, that that is not only nonsense. It's done right dangerous
To make those suggestions
So you have to be careful there's a lot of people out there that say they're nutritionists and they got some degree in the mail
online or something or not against that or knocking that but you just
Without any knowledge of physiology
There's been books written on things that are completely physiologically wrong from
And then and then recommendations that have flown around the internet from doing you know, taking baking soda as a as
Orally a mixing it with honey or maple syrup and then and then eating it as a cure for cancer
It's just nonsense and it's physiologically incorrect
To you know testing your pH with your urine pH and buying pH strips and testing your salivary pH to get your body alkaline
This is completely nonsense from somebody who doesn't understand the physiology of your body's buffering systems
And it's just dangerous thought and so I'm here to try to
Rebuttal some nonsense that's out there
And then tell you that you know there's you know medical
Professionals that say
That nutrition is a nonsense
So there's a balance between what's real what's what's good for us and what's kind of just hype
Um and and what could be possibly bad for us
So this would fall into the hype it's not bad for you if you want to put cancer on your body but that's just fine
I don't think there's anything wrong with that but is is that like a magical spot to store castor oil
That God gave you no, it's um
So
Everybody knows the belly button is to store salt when you're eating celery and bad to dip yourself
Sorry, that was a joke but no, so it's not it's so just that would fall into the hype category and
There's nothing wrong with it, but um
Let's talk about that